Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
This will be my video
for the Witcher Season 3 Ending.
They've aired all the episodes now.
Obviously, Henry Cavill
is leaving his girl, so it's a huge deal.
All explain
what's going to happen with that.
the last couple of episodes kind of
explain how they're going to address that.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
careful for spoilers for the ending.
If you haven't seen The Witcher Season
three episode eight
But at the end of the finale, Geralt
stands up for a group of travelers
that are being denied passage
by Nilfgaard and soldiers
because they can't pay enough bribe money,
which Gilt himself had just done.
He kills the soldiers in retaliation,
but leaves one alive, telling him
to go back to Nilfgaard and tell Emperor
Emhyr that he's coming for him.
Setting up a Geralt versus Emperor Emhyr
fight at some point in the final season.
whatever that winds up being season
four or season five, whatever they have
planned, they haven't actually shown
Emperor Emhyr doing any real fighting yet.
But he boasted about his exploits earlier
this season in this war
to get rid of the usurper earlier
in the timeline retake his throne.
So he's meant to be a good fighter.
will give forwards
trots out the fake version of Ciri
to try and trick Emperor Emhyr.
If it wasn't clear,
he understands instantly that it's a fake
and just goes along with it.
So
Vilgefortz won't suspect that he knows
The whole thing between the
two of them is
they have a very emperor and Darth
Vader Star Wars kind of relationship,
like they're both using each other,
which will go for
it's talked about earlier this season.
they both want Ciri
for completely different reasons.
And Boromir wants to marry Ciri,
which is already kind of messed up enough.
Like if you didn't think
they'll go for its wander for messed up
reasons, Emperor Emhyr also wants her
for very messed up reasons.
suddenly you're getting these Game
of Thrones twins as kind of vibes like,
Oh, wow, they're going way beyond
Jaime and Cersei kind of stuff here.
he wanted to marry Ciri
to legitimize his claim on Cintra,
and it's just part of his idea
taking over the entire continent.
knowing that this girl is a fake,
he marries her quickly
and then sends her
to like the outskirts of the empire
and just forgets about her
for a little while,
but slowly falls in love with her,
even knowing
that she's a fake and just continues
the marriage Vilgefortz wants.
Ciri because he wants to take her power
for his own.
He wants to take over the world
using her elder blood abilities.
you notice this messed up face
that happened in the explosion
where Ciri took off through the portal,
then they end the episode,
which is Geralt walking down the road.
No hint is how they're going to explain
Liam Hemsworth showing up with his face
at the beginning of season
four Episode one, which makes me think now
this is actually a big deal,
that there will be no explanation
and Liam Hemsworth will just show up
in season four episode one
and none of the other characters
will address it
or think that anything is different
or amiss.
kind of like a Game of Thrones.
Dario Nakamura's Twist End Screen
started the character in earlier seasons.
Then the next season,
right after he debuted,
it was a totally different actor
playing the character in
Nobody on the Show ever addressed it or
thought that it was weird the writers just
all pretended like it had always been
the same actor playing the character.
Thanks to the Lord of the Rings, Heroes
of Middle Earth and EA
for sponsoring the video.
It's a new mobile role playing
game on Android and iOS from capital games
and EA that lets
you collect your favorite characters
from Tolkien lore in Explore Middle Earth.
Relive your favorite stories
along with brand new ones
they created for the game
based on the original Tolkien novels.
You can download it for free
using the link in the description
or scan the QR code.
I'll put in the video up here.
make your own fellowship
and use awesome solo and team up abilities
that can change the course of battle.
Like Legolas and Gimli together,
who were great as a combo for DPS.
You can use. Kilian Feely
from the Hobbit movies.
Their team up is mostly focused on party
buffs and healing.
You can even use the NoSQL in play
as darker characters,
like using their dark magic for range DPS.
there's a bunch of different options
that you can play and explore in the game.
The light or the shadow side,
like the side of Sauron Guild campaigns,
PvP options
where you can play against your friends
or help each other
as part of the same guild.
Join forces with the Iraqi lady
Alien Strider Frodo
Baggins, the great goblin to battle across
new story driven campaigns.
and they introduce new characters and
events from the lore on a regular basis,
including special legendary characters
from the lore.
So you can collect brand new characters
that are new each month.
So be sure to check it out.
way more.
Attention is given to series
storyline In these last three episodes,
the story is starting to pivot
to be more and more centered around her
just in general.
that's
why there were so many Ciri episodes
in like an entire episode of Ciri
in the Desert talking to Falkor
in very little of Geralt in the other
characters no makes a little more sense.
Why Henry Cavill
would be more ready to leave
if they're not going to be using him
that much in the last couple of seasons
during all of series last
couple of episodes in her final scene.
That's a coming fight between her
and the real Falka to pay off a longer
running theory of mine that the real Falka
will wind up being the true white Frost
main villain behind Everything,
who's also controlling the wild hunt
In the final scene, she gives the rats
the fake alias name Falka,
which is a reference to that real Falka,
who she had just gotten done talking to
for an entire episode.
Princess
Falka was believed to have been long dead
by the start of the main timeline
in the Witcher story.
Geralt was born decades after
she was supposed to have been executed.
she was the firstborn daughter of Rodney
King redneck.
She led an uprising against him
in her younger stepbrothers.
both Falka and her father
were supposed to have perished
during that original uprising.
So her connection to Ciri, though,
is that the adopted daughter of Phocas
stepmother was an ancestor of Ciri,
basically making Falkor series ancestor.
what do think they're going to do
on the show,
though, is they're going to play up
that connection between their two families
like ancestor and descendant.
The other thing about her final scene,
too, is that
there was this whole rebellion that Falka
led against her father, who was royalty.
And they want to foreshadow Ciri
doing the same thing against Emperor Ymir.
So her storyline series storyline is meant
to mirror Falka's storyline
Episode seven,
you could basically think of
as the Falka episode, even though it's
more like Ciri in the dessert episode.
the interesting thing about Falka
is that when she appears to Ciri
in Episode seven,
she's not the same type of hallucination
that the other people in series
family are.
they don't explain
how she's able to accomplish this,
but we'll get to that in a second because
I think they're using her scenes to set up
a big twist in season four and beyond.
she gives Ciri a big PowerPoint
tutorial on her back story being labeled
an insane princess, just like
Ciri believes that she's being labeled.
She points out their similarity
is how the system failed her failure.
Ultimately, all of society
failed in all those problems,
the wheel, quote unquote, keeps turning.
Things keep happening the same way again
and again and again.
If she wanted to destroy the world
and now wants Ciri to destroy the world.
So she's kind of trying to bait
Ciri trick Ciri into destroying the world.
they talk about the legends around Falka
having been a demon accursed
elven monster, the stories were half true.
She's more of a pure, magical being now,
more of like a metaphorical monster.
Because notice doesn't her voice
sounds similar to the voice
of the White Frost
during the Witcher Blood Origin series.
Like they're trying
to change the book's story a little bit
because in the original story,
the White Frost is like the technical
main villain of the entire
like all Witcher universe,
the White Frost is the main villain,
But they treat it
more like a force of nature.
More like a coming ice age
that's going to consume the planet.
Not like an actual person,
which the show is changing.
I think Volga tells Ciri
about how she was burned at the stake
in how she used fire magic.
And it sounds like she found a way
to transcend that form and continue on
is like this pure energy based magical
being like she began to consume
more and more energy.
That's how she wound up
on the other planet in this form.
And she's just trying to consume
other planets, gain more power,
that would explain why the real vodka
is still alive in present day.
Like thousands of years later,
she's still alive and she's not an elf.
Technically, she wasn't born an elf,
even if she hadn't been burned
at the stake, she should have been dead
And it looks like
the show is setting her up
to be like an evil mirror for Ciri,
someone who faced similar circumstances,
both betrayed by their fathers,
by society,
whatever she wants to call it, in twisted
fog of evil.
So it's more like a Ciri versus an evil
version of Ciri that they're setting up
instead of Ciri versus like a giant
white blizzard like you see in the games
Falka even tell Ciri
she has the power to change the world.
Like Falka herself felt like
she had the power to change the world.
And now you do in present day as well.
when she says Ciri would be the last,
I think the idea is that she's trying
to trick Ciri into using her true
like full power to destroy the world
in allow fog into the world so that
she can also steal serious power herself.
like I
said, though, there's nowhere in the books
that they actually suggest
that the real fog became the white frost.
I think that's meant to be a big change
the show is making.
So they actually end the show
with like Ciri versus another person
instead of Ciri versus
like a force of nature, like Ciri
hacking away with her sword,
a giant blizzard.
one of the other problems, too,
is that the actual white Frost main
villain isn't something they really get
into too much during the books.
Like the book story actually ends
before she actually faces the white Frost.
you don't really see that happen
until the events of The Witcher
three video game in all the Witcher
video game story picks up
after The Witcher book Story ends.
the other teaser in all this too,
like setting up this big conflict
between Syrian fuck or white frost
however you want to think about her
is that Falka even implies
that she's going to try and kill Ciri.
Ultimately
What do you think she means is
she's trying to get Sarah
to sacrifice herself to give Falka access
to all the power that she wants.
Basically sacrificed herself for Falka
In the teaser that they go out on,
like where she gives the fake name
Falka to the other rats, The alias
in the face that she makes
is meant to show
that she might actually do it, Like Ciri
might actually try to burn the world down.
The other thing that they get into these
last couple of episodes I was surprised by
was them doing the space unicorns.
I didn't think
they'd be able to pull this off,
but they have kind of a twist
the way they include it.
So the whole idea is the space.
Unicorns are a real thing.
In The Witcher universe.
They're just cosmic beings that are able
to navigate the multiverse naturally
just because their own biological power
aired it in the wild.
Hunt tried to hunt them down
and use their power to their own ends
so they can travel the multiverse
and conquer different planets.
within the context of the TV show,
I think they're meant to be like
diametric opposites.
To fall
because of the wild hunt
are hunting down the unicorns
and they serve the white frost Forca
That means that Falkor probably hates
the unicorns.
Do Towards the end of that episode, Forca
also tries to corrupt
Ciri by getting her to use Fire Magic,
which is a leader into season four.
Season four probably going to be based
on the next book in the series
Baptism of Fire.
They make a lot of references
to being baptized in fire
during that particular
part of the episode.
I also think that Falkor is the one who
engineered the scenario where the monster
attacked them, almost killing the unicorn
to beat Ciri into using fire
was he engineered this whole scenario
to try and corrupt Ciri?
here's the thing with season four, though.
If season four
is going to be based on baptism of fire,
they probably have to make a bunch
of changes because for the most part,
there's an a ton of stuff
that happens in this book.
there's way more plot related stuff
that actually happens
in the next book after this, which
they probably wait for season five to do.
during baptism of fire.
Everybody is still pretty much separated.
Has their own adventures
like Ciri goes off with the rats
and has more adventures with them.
Geralt has his own adventures.
Separately from Yennefer,
Yennefer tries to create The Lodge of
Sorcerers is with the other women
that survived that they ended qu.
but then after that.
During the last book
things really start getting going again.
girl meets Avallach
from the Witcher Blood origin,
the other time traveling elf.
He tells him more about the prophecy.
Yennefer starts
going after Vilgefortz again
and what they'll do with the final season
is they'll probably combine
with the Witcher game storyline
with Ciri against the white frost
but they'll change it to be folk
pretending to be this white Frost villain.
generally. The finale was not that great.
Like episode six
actually started out as a banger
and it was a pretty good episode,
but then it just got worse from there.
know a lot of people be bummed to see
Henry Cavill leave the world girl,
but like I said, it's probably because
they're not going to be using Général
a whole bunch
in the final couple of seasons.
So Henry Cavill is probably,
you know what?
I think I'm going to go do something else.
that's something else is a big Warhammer
series that he's developing.
He's a huge Warhammer geek.
I've already done a much bigger trailer
video for his Warhammer series
in the Warhammer movies that he's planning
and working on right now.
I'll post the link for that at the end
of this and down in the description below.
It's going to be a couple of years
before that.
His screens,
if there's any other references
or Easter eggs
that I didn't talk about
from the ending in this video
just write them below in the comments
or any other questions
you have about what they're going to be
doing with the last couple of seasons.
But right now is me posting this video.
We're in the middle of a giant strike.
So pretty much everything
has been postponed until that's done.
probably going to be another two years
before Season 4 premieres.
click here for that Henry Cavill Warhammer
trailer video and click here
for all my other Comic-Con trailer videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and toss a coin to your Witcher!